the largest charities in the world right
now
are banks um essentially there's
something called
um a donor advised fund where you can
instead of giving to a charity now you
can
give to or give let's say you want to
give the red cross
instead of giving the red cross now you
put it to fidelity charitable
which has its own 501c3 you get your tax
deduction
you can invest that money and put in the
stock market it grows
it grows tax-free and then you go into
fidelity go on their online portal and
give to the red cross or give every
chair you want
which theoretically is amazing because
you're going to give more over time and
you're going to this but the
the byproduct of this is that we have a
society where
the largest if you google right now the
largest areas in the world you're going
to get four or five banks
um and i'm curious for both of you
how that impacts like the donors or the
field you work in well i think that
philanthropy in general is my experience
has been
very risk-averse and
look it makes sense if you're you know
driven by being risk averse
because you want to you know make sure
that you're advising
someone right to make a good
donation then if you're playing it safe
it's really really hard to get
and investments into innovative
solutions so you know when it's driven
by
again uh being risk-averse and a culture
that is focused on
less on innovative solutions more and
like how can i make my clients happy
then it's hard it's just hard to to
invest in innovative things
i mean if you look at how a lot of
philanthropy dollars are even invested
um that follows amanda's you know
comment about how just their
philanthropy traditionally has been very
conservative
um you know i i'd like to you know
believe that that that has shifted some
and will continue to shift more i think
the bulk is is still
pretty pretty traditional which means
pretty conservative
and i think yes as more and more folks
particularly times like now
really i'd like to think are starting or
should be thinking more of
well gosh you know is our giving can
this be the seed corn for future change
can we put something in now can we take
a big bet a big risk
here and really there's an organization
that i like that i know
that we've vetted that we've treated as
we have a r d budget for a giving
so we are going to do some evaluation
we're going to work closely with them
and let's take a big bet on this
you know i mean for folks who invested
in in
zoom or or bitcoin or tesla
let's find an organization that does
great work and let's take great risk and
maybe those this you know company
calls for change will have a similar
rate of return of three four five
hundred percent
but there's a component of risk and and
i think that more folks are maybe
seeing that as as we are in you know
where we are now with cobit 19 um
and and hopefully we see more change
there i'm hopeful uh
you know we're cautiously optimistic
their folks start making big bets on on
amazing ideas
it's so funny because the space i was in
the philanthropy side there's always so
much hope
um and then when i was in the politics
fourth industrial revolution side it was
so much despair
um but i love it and i think
so one of the things that i'm really
really passionate about at the film
topic space is
is risk because people
don't people take plenty of risk with
their for-profit dollars
all day long um that's like what the
stock market is yet when it comes to
charity we're like
hey we don't know if that's gonna work
or it's like hey
i can't have any negative pr in my
giving or
hey like whatever the excuses and it's
the problem is
the problem is the way this is set up
that the people who
need to take risk are wealthy
people who can give back that it's like
the individual donors because
governments can't take risk because then
elected officials get crushed businesses
can't take that risk on philanthropic
stuff because they have to hit their
bottom line they're already taking
enough risk
otherwise so it literally is on families
to fail
and try if you have a hundred thousand
if the wealthiest folks to put that and
that's where
i think a lot of innovation needs to
come from i'm in i'm curious
tell us more we've kind of skipped over
and it's like maybe i buried the lead a
bit so tell us more about some amazing
stuff you're doing and i'll give the
context of
how we got connected is not just to bill
but you were connected with evelyn with
a lot of your work on the survivor's
bill of rights which
i i can't tell you how amazing it is
because it's one thing to feel good and
talk a good game and say the right
things that is important words matter
but so do action so so for you to take
something that a lot of people are very
passionate about and turn into
legitimate policy
um frankly bipartisan policy in certain
places um
game changing and rare i'm so i'm sorry
i'm fanboying
but tell me more please no i'm so thank
you
thank you so much for saying that
because i think that
look the field of uh non-profit industry
of activism in general
of course there are these thought
leaders right who are
very important yes raising awareness
very very important how do we translate
these ideas into action and
in order to do so how do we do it in a
way where we don't
step on landmines uh that actually hold
us back
and there is certainly especially when
you engage in
uh legal change right like writing
legislation
you have to work with people um and let
me just tell you
first of all i'm a super nerd so my
background's in astrophysics
that really informs how i operate
and also uh with this idea
of this being larger than myself
right and having a very clear
um finish line uh so what do i mean by
that
um when you are able to
have a very clear goal everything else
kind of just falls to the wayside right
so if the goal is to
pass these civil rights then there is a
very
actually a simple track to that it's you
must work in a bipartisan manner you
must get
x amount of votes right yes of course
it's much harder than what i'm saying
but i've done it 33 times now
all of my laws have been bipartisan and
it literally makes
rise the most successful legislative
reform vehicle in modern u.s history
that's so impressive and so sad in some
ways it is so sad
actually literally there was this i
often don't bring up this data point
because you know people have feelings
about it but
if you look at the presidential
candidates that ran
um most of them have passed zero laws
that's average
zero zero loss we have passed i passed
33.
and the reason for that is well you know
we are
centered on community we're centered on
people and we also
think strategically about how to advance
these rights and how to work across the
isle
um it's so sad to say that being able to
exercise radical embassy and then marry
that with data-driven processes
is innovative but honestly very very few
people are doing well
literally no one has a track record so
um there's that but
it's just it's important to have a plan
and that plan
being driven by what it is that you're
the change that you're trying to make
i know that feeling where it's um i had
it with suit up a non-profit i started
which was small scale but i had a lot
with andrew where it's like
where you're you're doing something and
you have a right message and it seems
very very rational to years like
like and it was like am i doing
something wrong because this seems
really really obvious and no one's
saying no
to me and sometimes the reality is the
only way
something's going to happen the only
reason it didn't happen yet is because
no one bothered to get up and do the
work
yeah so yeah tell tell us mormon about
the work
think as if you're in like a movie about
a heist right like ocean's 11 or
something what's the first process to
get like the thing
right if you're like diamond instead of
a diamond is civil rights
you must analyze your landscape you know
you must know
what the exit points are you must know
what the rules are
if you want to win a game you have to
know the rules and then you have to know
it well enough to know
how to break the rules right so
it's so important to be educated about
the processes by which
i'm going to talk about the type of
change that rise engages in which is
creating laws right and centering it
around the communities that are affected
by it putting them at the center
so um i can't believe you know that
that's innovative but
it really is because so much
of what people feel um especially
you know reiterating the last
presidential race is hey i don't feel
like i have agency
right like i you know my family's going
through all these issues but who's
looking out for us and also why does my
voice matter
right i think that's was said in so many
different ways
and that's a real problem if we live in
a democracy that's of the people by the
people for the people
then the people need to feel like they
have a part
of this country that's working and
serving them right so
why does that happen it's happened
because there has been um
a considerable effort to i know this
sounds spicy
gaslight people into forgetting their
constitutional right to petition the
government what do i mean by that
our education most people don't know
that they could write their own law
most people don't know how a bill
becomes a law right um
and all of these fundamental things are
so so important so that's what rise
justice labs does
we have a program called school of hope
um and it literally teaches people
the blueprint for how to pass laws you
are tying
all this passion and frankly rhetoric
and a lot of things the left is good at
we are very good at drawing a line in
the sand we are very good
at saying you're on my team or not the
team right but
we are not good as democrats excluding
the past literally just the presidential
election in 2020 we're not good at
winning
we're not good at executing like
generally speaking i'm obviously over
generalizing
and there's a lot of things you can say
about mitch mcconnell and i have a lot
of thoughts on that man
but one thing he's very good at sadly is
winning
oh yeah he gets a lot if you look at
this man's track record in terms of
supreme court justices
and impeachment trials uh one if you on
go down list he wins
all the time and democrats need to start
winning because we have the right ideas
we just don't
have the right game plan one of the
reasons i think you're the future of
flint because you've taken
all the rhetoric and all the passion and
turned it into not just activism but
organized activism where you can rally
the troops around the cot
how has that worked for you guys and
what sort of stuff have you
actually done that what have you done to
help that work so
activism to me is like straight up
voltage
right and organizing is directed energy
and what we do is directed energy of
course both are necessary in building
movements and creating change
and each person has their part to play
in a social movement we need the people
who are protesting we need the thought
leaders we need people who are with the
megaphones
we also need people who know the rules
right who knows what unanimous consent
is
and what redlining means all of these
things that are so important to the
actual
technicality of moving something through
the existing body that we have
right so in order for us to actually
create the change that we want to see
one
it's so basic but know know what it is
that you want
and be informed about what it is that
you want so our first lesson
right um in in rise when you're accepted
into the program
is to do immense research right
it's when you before you ever step into
the office of a senator have your bill
draft ready
right how are they supposed to know more
than you i mean yeah i get it it's their
job to
you know make the policy but also if you
want to
increase your chances of success then
tell them what it is that you want tell
them why it is it's bad that they won't
do this
and also help them see your perspective
right so that means analyzing your issue
and knowing your thing before you go in
that's really critical um hopeonomics is
actually again i'm a nerd so it really
comes back from a nerdy place
star trek people will know this but for
me the way that i
teach people hopeonomics is to envision
a four layered chess board it's
literally
so four layers all stacked on each other
it's a game
of chess and each layer represents a
mode of thinking
when you move a chess piece on any of
these layers it affects the rest of the
game
right so the first layer it goes from
most concrete to most abstract the first
layer
is mission and facts what i just said
know your issue
the second layer is narrative right how
are you gonna have that emotion
towards that the third layer is
coalition building
which is how do you work across the
aisle right and the last layer
is what i like to call the human
condition um
and honestly i actually you know modeled
this
off of um graham allison's uh theory of
how to deal with dictators in the cuban
missile crisis wow
okay yeah yeah yeah but you know instead
of dictators it's for
politicians it's not you know what to
think but how to think how do you
strategize right and get to
your finish line i'll tell you this from
humanity forward where andrew and i were
running an organization that was trying
to get cash relief passed we did a lot
of
programs we did a lot of testing we did
all stuff and like the best roi it
wasn't even close was we hired someone
who had like very little experience
doing this
just to go harass our congressmen and
women
and that actually got the stimulus check
passed that's
literally what worked um so
yes completely agree it's like and
that's a big thing andrew like trying to
make the like
plumbing cool um which i think you're
doing really well
bill have you seen it any other
organizations like trying
this like or is this so out of left
field
in the philanthropic game that we need
to spread the word high and wide for
people to start keeping up with the man
they're like what's
like what are you seeing there i have
not seen anyone do it to the level
of what amanda rise are doing at all i
mean
it's i mean a lot of folks i mean you
have the image of schoolhouse rock
you know and you got a sad bill at the
top of the hill you know
and but who actually to your point zack
who actually
is is doing that who who i mean i
i grew up in tallahassee florida and
there are a ton of lawyers and a total
lobbyist at the state capitol
and you know of course you know how is
law passed well there's lobbyists
involved and they talk to the
the staff the local representatives the
senate
i mean it goes through the process you
know i mean that that's
that's it i mean a lot of folks don't
really know and and this
sounds so trite but i i can't think of
another phrase but
what a man and her team are doing to me
they're really democratizing democracy
it's making it so real and and they're
helping you do it and they are helping
you along the way
you have to do the work but they're
there to really help shape you do that
so
i'm not i'm i'm sure there are no meta
i'm sure has additional insight into
this but this model i think is
incredibly successful it's not just
which
it's you know there's proof and concept
you know uh building on amanda
and and the work that she's done um to
write so many
wrongs and and then other folks have
their
own passion interest area too whether
they live in tallahassee or to egg
florida or wherever they live
they can make this change and they can
make it happen and being able to have
that structure
where it's just not this kind of
amorphous piece it really is i truly
believe this
really are democratizing democracy
that's how you make real change
[Music]
you